Okay so now let's look at order blocks. So we'll enable order blocks. So there
's a couple
different things here, we'll turn off liquidity for now. So I've enabled all
order blocks and they
are basically any direction of trend and essentially the logic behind the order
block is the kind of
the fading cell momentum before an aggressive move or the fading buying
momentum before an
aggressive move. So you can see here that this was an order block and again we
've got it kind of
accented as a line. How I personally use it is I'm more interested in the
general range
that's created from the line as opposed to only the line itself. So you can see
that this is the
this is the order block range. You can kind of see the range and we move. You
can see that price
comes into this level quite nicely and moves. Now does every single order block
work? Obviously not.
I have a cell before I buy. This is the order block. It gets tagged and it goes
. Again order blocks
in here and yeah it's only going to show the these ones. So another thing we
can do as well is if
you want to add refined order blocks. If you want to refine your order blocks
you'll notice that
this level specifically. If you look at it before it becomes refined.
So we'll turn off refined. This order block becomes higher. If you refine it,
it becomes lower.
And that is because instead of it being the whole move it kind of just moves to
being a singular candle. I don't use refined order blocks unless I'm looking at
a really high
time frame. So we'll look at daily for example. Probably a better idea to look
at the daily.
To be quite frank. This is where you could probably use refined order blocks.
You see that this is
an old refined order block that gets hit trades away gets hit again. So this
order block just
continuously reloads and holds. I always use my order blocks bias aligned only.
So I only want to see bullish order blocks. If I'm bullish I want to see
bullish order blocks.
If I'm bearish I want to see bearish order blocks plain and simple. And again
if I go replay price
which is a random level. This is it's also relative to the price leg.
So this will be bias aligned only. You'll only see bearish order blocks if the
trend is
at current bearish. So you can see here we have a bearish order block here we
have a bearish order
block. Now when we trade through it it becomes obsolete. Okay I didn't trade
through it. This
one held. This one's here. Again we create a bullish order block. Trade through
it becomes obsolete.
This is the old order block. Trade through it becomes obsolete. This one holds
as you can see.
A new one gets created. But when you trade through them they become obsolete.
And so there's a kind of big misconception about order blocks but it's
something that
for the most part is important to people when people use. Again sometimes a
bullish order block
can also become a bearish order block if we kind of move through and it still
means the
criteria. Again it's still built off of kind of objective role-based principles
. But what you'll
notice for me is especially for a 15 minute time frame I don't really use order
blocks a lot to be
quite frank with you. It's something I used to rely heavily on but these days
no. If you go and look
at my strategy you go look at my back testing you'll see that I don't really
use order blocks a lot
because I find them they're more of a perfectionism model than anything. The
reality is this price
doesn't always react from order blocks. Sometimes it reacts from imbalances.
Sometimes it reacts from
fair value gaps. Sometimes it reacts from sweeps of liquidity and so expecting
price to just move
from an order block isn't really going to help you. And so we've added it in
here because it's still
something important. You can see the logic based off of it. Displacement
candles with
fair value gaps compliments. So everywhere the block in here will have to
create a displacement
through the order through a level and leave behind an area of imbalance. And
then bias aligned will
only show you order blocks that are aligned with the current swing direction.
So if you're bullish
you're going to show you bullish order blocks if you're bearish you're going to
show you bearish
order blocks. Now I don't really have too much to tell you about order blocks.
I use order blocks
more so on a one or five minute timeframe when I'm framing a trade idea. I'll
kind of probably
show you that more when I come to the execution but still I use order blocks
fair value gaps and
liquidations for my kind of confirmation. But order blocks are just there. They
may confuse you
or they may come in handy for you. It's not something that you really need to
rely on but
I mean what would an SMC engine be kind of without order blocks to be quite
honest with you.
If we go to more of a five minute timeframe again it's not going to be that
relevant because
there has to be context we won't refine them. And order block isn't just
relevant without context
because so many order blocks just get traded through. So many order blocks are
not important.
Some of them hold really well. Some of them don't hold. I think order blocks is
something
in the SMC community that has become heavily over used especially for areas of
interest.
I personally prefer just trend direction and price action. So for me for
example like let's say
we're bullish right and let's say price is starting to come back and let's say
there's an order block
in here. And let's say you know Asia logo is taken out in here and the one
minute timeframe
shifts something like this. I'm not going to sit here and wait for price to
come and hit this
order block. I'm going to be executing longs to go higher and we won't have hit
the order block.
So I guess the best way for me to actually explain your order blocks is how I
actually use them.
They can be useful but the reality is is that for the most part I don't rely on
them.
And you'll see when I show you my settings I don't have all the blocks toggled
on.
It's something even similar if ever you go up. So that's all the blocks. I'll
be totally
honest with you they're not super important. You can use them they can help but
they are only
they are very concentrated in their context. Like you should only be looking at
an order block
that is created in this price lake from high to low. If there's an order block
in here
it has relevance. But if there's a you know a bullish order block that's here
or a bearish
order block that's above here then they're just not relevant. That's why I
asked the team to have
a bias aligned only model for order blocks. And again if you look at different
indicators you'll
see all types of order blocks. The reality is is it's an over relied upon
concept.
The most important is going to be trend liquidity in sessions. Order blocks are
kind of like a
fancy add on. But they still do work and I do use them primarily for entries.
So if there's for
example a 15 minute bullish trend and the one minute shifts like this and this
is my five minute
order block that will be my trade. That'll be my entry. And so that's kind of
primarily how
I use order blocks. Like if we go to let's go to use the CAD and find the trade
that I took.
What we can see here and this is basically the primary model of the strategy I
want to turn
sessions on. You can see in here what's happened. We are bearish. This is the
swing high. This is
the swing low. We had Asia and London equal highs. We sweep them out as New
York begins to open and
then we get the confirmation. So we're already most likely set to go short. You
can see here that
this is the swing low. So the moment that we break that swing low now we've
changed character.
And this is where an order block for example would be something that I would
consider. But
again it's not the only thing that I would use because I would also use an opt-
in for fair value
gaps. But this is where the order blocks have been born. So you can see that
this is the primary
order block. This one. This one is from an old M15. It's still part of the
price leg. But this
would be the order block that I would use if I was going to use an order block.
In this instance
I would honestly opt-in for fair value gap. It's situational. This is where you
'll learn more in
the backtesting. But that would be the order block that I would use for the
trade idea.
And you can see it's in this instance you can't get a more perfect entry than
that.
And so order blocks are something that are very subtle. There are a thousand
order blocks
a day. And a handful of them are useful. That's why choosing the right ones is
everything. That's why we have bias aligned. That's why for me order blocks are
an entry
confirmation. Not a direction, directional context. That's what liquidity and
structure is for.
And so this is this is where you start becoming a master of smart money
concepts is when you truly
understand what concepts are, what they are for and how they should be used.
This is kind of
discretionary context profiling. This is where my traders go wrong. They just
think that they
think that order blocks and and market structure are equally relevant. They
think order blocks
and fair value gaps are equally relevant. They think order blocks and sessions
and previous days
high is the same as trend lines and like they just think they think concepts
and they think that
all the concepts should be right or everything should be perfect or they're all
as important as
each other. And as you go through the strategy and as you go through my test
and my own personal
trading, you'll you'll quickly find that they are context driven. Same with
fair value gaps.
Again, even if we look at let's look at this trade here, for example. This is
again another
beautiful USD CAD trade. 15 minute is first things first and sessions. So what
do we see here?
We see that we have a bearish trend. So swing high, swing low, 15 minute order
blocks. And
now we're inside of the order block and the 15 minute. But we don't have to be
here. For me,
the reason that I'm looking to go short here is this session liquidity we've
taken. We had Asia
high and London high and New York swept them both in the context of the trend.
We are likely
going to be getting irreversible. And so after we get that, it's down to the
one minute to look for
confirmation. The one minute is bullish. So we're not interested in anything
right now,
because the woman is bullish. Swing low for the one minute is down here. We
liquidate it. It
doesn't count. Now we take it out. So now we actively change character. So on
the five minute
timeframe, for example, is there an order block in here? No, there's not even a
bearish order block.
But what there obviously is is a fair value gap. And again, we're going to have
bias aligned
only for our gaps. That's because the 15 minute is bullish. So these are
showing bearish. These
are showing bullish order blocks and M15 levels. Okay. I might have to tinker
with this a little
bit if I'm going to be honest with you. I might make it so that it's relative
to the M15
for the five minutes specifically. Okay, so we'll turn this off. And we want to
have our gaps.
Okay. Now we see that we have the bearish M5 FA gap. So there's no order. There
's no bearish
order block in here. But there's a fair value gap. And so this is an example
where again,
order block is just completely irrelevant to me, over than the order box that
we're coming from.
But for me, this is a, it's a fair value gap setup.
And you can see perfectly into the fair value gap price goes away. And now you
can see the order
blocks beginning to appear on the five minute timeframe and the fair value gaps
. But again,
fair value gaps and order blocks are both very similar concepts to me. I can
cover them both
simultaneously. They are very there to be cherry picked. Not every fair value
gap is the same.
Not every order block is the same. I guess this is kind of order blocks and
fair value gaps in one
really. Not every order block and fair value gap are equal. Order blocks and
fair value gaps should
only be used in relation to your trading setup. They are, for me personally,
entry confirmations.
They are not really relevant. Like you look how many fair value gaps are here.
Look how many
order blocks here. Do you think those mean much to me? Honestly, they don't.
Because price trades
through fair value gaps and away from fair value gaps all the time. And so if
you're a,
if you're a junkie for fair value gaps, you'll end up looking at all the, all
the fair value gaps.
For me, it's liquidity first. There's an old block. There's a fair value gap.
This for me would be
more of a fair value gap entry. They become important to me only relative to
entries. And so if we now have
don't, this is what becomes important to me. This order blocks this for value
gap
after the entry confirmation. And they're the ones that you'll see whole time
and time again.
And so that's another lesson and takeaway that I would give for people is
order blocks and fair value gaps as valuable as they are.
Don't come close to structure and sessions, but they're all used for specific
purposes.
Order blocks, fair value gaps, primarily entry related after confirmation. And
so I guess that
kind of, that will bring me full circle into kind of how I would use it. This
is how I would use it
before I'm even taking the, the trade in New York session. This is how I use
the indicator.
And these are my settings. So first and foremost, I'm spending most of my time
in the 15 minute time
frame. I don't have, this is what the indicator will look like at base model.
And again,
you can play around with this. You can use it. I like to turn the current week
only off. I want
to see previous week sessions personally. This is what it will look like if you
just have everything
toggled on, which is why it can become a little bit overwhelming for people. So
for me, the first
thing that I'm doing is I'm turning off the internal. I'm enabling sessions,
Asia, London, New York,
current week only now. I allow the dashboard in here. I usually use it as small
or tiny.
So you can make it small so that it doesn't take up a port, a large portion of
your screen,
which we obviously don't want. You can change it. You want it top left, top
right, middle right,
middle left, like whatever. You can change your appearance. So for example,
bullish colors.
Maybe like that for you at the beginning, bearish is bearish is red. Again, I
prefer minimalism.
I prefer just a neutral stance. I don't like swing point labels. I don't need
to see if
it's a low or high or low or low. I'm okay enough to see that is it a high or
low or myself.
Liquidity. I don't like to have session highs or pre-open highs and lows. Why?
Because I can see
them. I can see Asia high and Asia low. I can see them. And so you'll see how
my chart becomes
quite minimalistic. Again, I personally opt in for a minimalism approach to my
my charts.
I like like an aesthetic minimalistic approach. And then even order blocks, I
turn, I have order
blocks turned off, especially whilst I am, especially whilst I am framing trade
ideas.
And so for the most part, my chart ends up looking this clean. I literally have
just sessions and
structure. I have sessions and structure. And so what I'm looking for,
my strategy is pro trend. Step one is trend direction. So you can see we have a
swing high here,
a swing low here, a break of structure. It tells me that we're bearish. So I
know we're bearish.
I know this is the high. I know this is the low. I have Asia high and Asia low
in here as my
liquidity. So now we've swept them. Step two is M15 trend. Step one is M15
trend. Step two is
session liquidity. I need to see a sweep out of some important session
liquidity below the swing
low. Step three is lower time frame structure. And again, this already built
into the indicator.
Because now I simply just go to a one minute timeframe. I look at this and I
see, okay,
the one minute is bullish. So can I short when the one minute is bullish? No,
of course I can't.
So I wait, I wait, oh, wait, oh, wait, oh, wait, oh, wait. And this is where
you can literally just
set an alert here. You could just put an alert at this level. Add an alert to
this level.
And when it gets hit, now you know you're ready to go. So now we've changed
character. So now
we're one minute bearish, 15 minute bearish. We've taken out the highs. Now
step four is my entry.
So for my entry, this is where you can get creative. This is where you can go
and toggle your
order blocks. Enable for value gaps by us aligned only. Enable order blocks by
us aligned only.
This is where you can add them. So you can see we've come from this old gap in
price that we're
still respecting. We've come from this old order block. We're still respecting
it. Now we have these
newly formed order blocks. Now you can start framing your your trade idea. And
for me,
I'm looking at this. And this is the favor you go. That's my stock placement.
Always a logical
stock placement. And we don't want to target. There is literally price is
begging to trade to
these lows, begging. What do we have so much liquidity at these lows? Asia low,
London low,
previous days low. The daily directional bias is bearish. We've closed below
the previous day.
We've opened up. This is an A plus setup. We've opened up previous days lows
down here.
Every every box is ticked to take this trade. It's a textbook trade. And for
the most part,
the indicator does it. The indicator tells me that we're bearish. The indicator
tells me
whether the liquidity is. I only look after the liquidity has been taken. The
indicator tells me
when the lower timeframe reversal is it tells me where the order block in the
fair value gap is.
And so it it's created by me for me because it makes my chart and easier.
Because all the
important levels, I don't have to find myself anymore. Price gets tagged in.
Price continue
trading lower. And price hits the target. And that's the trade. And actually it
's technically
five R for my target. And that's five R trade. And that's pretty much the
indicator doing
the majority of the work. And so I know that there's a lot on there. Again, I
prefer a
minimalistic approach, even for me personally. Like the order blocks and fair
value gaps are great,
especially if you if you're not, if you don't feel competent yet, then use them
. But for me,
do you think I need it to show where the order block is with the fair value gap
? It's of course
not because I created it. I literally designed my rules. I don't need it to
know that I can
already see it. So for the most part, I just understand, okay, there's my entry
. There's the
order block. There's the fair value gap. It's perfect entry level. I just place
it. And so
to recap, what I have on my charts at all times non-negotiable is the swing M15
,
the sessions, the previous days high previous days low previous weeks high
previous weeks low.
So it's mainly trend structure sessions liquidity and extra liquidity for
previous days high previous
days low. I have this as well so that I can just see them all put time frame
structure. And yeah, that is honestly in a nutshell.
What we are, what we do, why we've released it to you. Again, please note that
this is this
indicators for me. I'm just simply giving you guys the opportunity to use what
I'm using that makes
my life easier. There are the rules and how to read them, how to frame them, my
personal settings,
and then a trade idea that is an executed trade that meets every criteria of my
trading strategy
is an A+ setup. And you can see how most of it is coded into the indicator
because again,
it just makes my life easier. Now, the one thing that there's no indicator for
is mental models and your inner edge because the truth is is no one and no
thing can save you
from yourself. No trading strategy, no indicator, no risk management can save
you from yourself.
If you have self-sabotage, if you have limiting beliefs, if you have an
unregulated nervous system,
if you have poor emotional control, if you have poor impulse control, no
strategy or indicator is
going to be your magic pill. That's the reality I want to tell you here, right
here, right now.
And if three months down the line, you're constantly breaking your rules or not
following rules,
there's no blame for that other than yourself. And if you're serious about
becoming a consistently
profitable trader and you're serious about achieving your goals, it's time to
just take responsibility,
own your actions, own your results that all we're doing. Everything in this
life
is a reaction of your actions. It's a universal law. And so, the most important
thing that I would
like to share with you and tell you is that nothing and no one can save you
from you. That's why I
created the NIH. You guys probably see it inside of school. The NIH I put
together is like,
I don't remember how many modules and episodes they were. I recorded it a while
ago, but
the biggest thing on my journey as being my inner edge, my psychology, my self-
control,
because I realized very early on that nothing was going to save me from me.
Only I can save me
from me. And as a trader, strategy is 33% of success. The other portion of it
is risk management,
and the most important portion of it all is your inner edge, your ability to
control yourself,
because if you don't execute your edge, then what good is your edge? So,
building an edge and
having an edge is a portion of success. But your own inner edge, your own self-
control,
that's a whole different scenario. That's why I created the inner edge. It
teaches you
your brain. The reality is in the problem that I've seen many traders face is
they know the
psychology is important, but they just have no idea where to start. How do you
start? So,
they read a couple books. Maybe they're retrading in the zone, which is a great
book, by the way.
But they read some psychology books and nothing changes, because information
doesn't change you.
Only pattern recognition, behavioral reinforcement, neuroscience, neuroplastic
ity will change you.
And so, if you're a trader that has these tools, that has the trading strategy
and all the back
tests in it, and you still aren't executing, I would genuinely employ you,
genuinely from
bar my heart, to go and take a look at that inner edge. I spent an entire year
building that program.
That is hands down by far my best work to date. More viable than any indicator
that I've built,
more valuable than the trading strategies that I've put together, is the time,
effort, research,
and structuring of the program that I call the inner edge. It will, at the very
least,
at the very least, it will help you to become totally unrecognizable as a
person in every area of
life. Period. It's everything that completely changed my life, not just inside
of trading,
but in everything, with money itself as a topic in relationships, in health, in
performance,
and of course, in trading. So, I'll leave you with that. And honestly, I really
wish you the best,
and I hope you get the value from this indicator, and you see the value in the
indicator,
because, I mean, it helps me. That's why I built it, and why not give it to you
. It doesn't
affect me. I don't get any alpha decay. So, yeah. Enjoy it. Use it. Put it to
work. And
if things aren't working, don't blame other people. Don't blame your tools. Don
't blame your strategy.
Accept your reality for what it is, which is a mirrored reflection of your
personality.
And until you change, nothing changes. So, please take your personal
development seriously. It's
been the most life-changing process for me personally. Trading for me has just
been a mirror
into my personal development. I think there is no greater profession in the
world that will challenge
you psychologically, that will force you to evolve than trading will. Truly, I
mean that.
So, yeah. I'll leave you with that. Hopefully, you enjoyed this mini-master
class, and hopefully,
you enjoy the inner edge as much as I enjoyed creating it. I'll see you guys
around.